fishka more military airbase where the
borders of Iraq Turkey and Syria meet
250 iraqi kurdish peshmerga troops
prepared for deployment to the front
where it's at its most dangerous most of
their weapons are decades old like their
Russian transport helicopters they were
bound for the Sinjar mountains which
since the bloody advance of Islamic
state have come to epitomize the
suffering of an entire region
since August the Sinjar mountains have
been the last resort of Yazidis fleeing
the murderous forces of Islamic state
deploying the Peshmerga fighters to
rescue the Yazidis a highly risky
operation the helicopters come under
attack so often that everything has to
go extremely fast after they land as
soon as the fighters jump out people are
already rushing in anyone remaining in
Sinjar is in deadly danger on this day
pesh MERGA started a successful
offensive against more than a thousand
heavily armed Islamists and managed to
evacuate eight thousand civilians in the
next days although this offensive proves
successful many kurdish forces have died
in the fight against the ious terrorists
commander mohammad koja complains that
they're hopelessly outgunned the
terrorists have huge numbers of modern
weapons our Kalashnikovs are useless
against them what we badly need our
tanks artillery and heavy machine guns
on begin how to shop in sn1 are these
people have lost everything except the
clothes they're wearing their future is
uncertain after the landing the wounded
were taken to hospitals the others have
been dispersed throughout the overfilled
refugee camps in kurdistan
the region of kurdistan has a wild
beauty all its own
we're on our way to the holiest site of
the Yazidis the religious minority lives
mainly in the Iraqi part of Kurdistan
we've been told this is a mystical place
la leash is the center of yazidis it's a
peaceful monotheistic religion older
than Judaism and Christianity and
definitely older than Islam natural
phenomena like the Sun and Moon even
sand storms and earthquakes are sacred
to the Yazidi they're considered signs
of their all-powerful God because the
Yazidi have no single Sacred Scripture
like the Bible Talmud or Koran radical
Muslim see them as infidels and
idolaters from the outset they've been
persecuted by their numerous enemies
the Yazidi keep up many traditions the
oil for the candles here has to be
stored in these nine hundred year old
amfar I the same room which has been
carved into the sheer rock houses the
wishing rock with their eyes closed the
faithful can throw a silk scarf onto a
small ledge if the scarf remains there
three times the wish will supposedly be
fulfilled this is the tomb of sheikh adi
eben musafir revered as the renewer of
the yazidi faith and incarnation of the
angel of God yaa Sidi luqman suleiman
explains that after his death in the mid
12th century the Yazidis veneration of
him was so strong that they made his
shrine the center of their religion
sheikh rd clearly defined for three
casts that form the basis of Yazidis am
to this day first there's the upper
caste of shakes then the pier or elders
and finally the murids or commoners
marriage is only allowed within a cast
it's a closed religion you're born areas
ed you can't become a convert we meet
the Baba shake equivalent to the Pope in
the yazidi faith he's pleaded for help
in Washington and Brussels the elderly
religious leader is desperate for one
thing peace Janet did a MOAB dammit the
terrorists shot at our brothers and
sisters in Sinjar with heavy weaponry
and destroyed all our villages killing
many people but what was worse for us is
that they've murdered our women and
abducted our girls we want to know
what's happened to those young women and
girls who were in the terrorists hands
and managed to escape our search begins
in the refugee camps like this one in
Kanker with 80,000 people the largest
camp in Iraqi Kurdistan almost everyone
here is traumatic
they try hard to create something
resembling normality women bake bread
for their families according to old
Kurdish traditions these people's sorrow
is palpable they not only lost all their
worldly belongings most have also lost
several family members the women
empowerment organization is one of more
than 20 NGOs here some of its workers
like Burton hard ahamed have themselves
narrowly escaped death
when I have no boner many girls smeared
their faces with dirt so they'd be so
ugly the Islamist wouldn't abduct them
but unfortunately they too were raped
that's what pains us the most as he is
ed woman i can say that we'd accept
anything how they could kill us
slaughter us but to be dishonored in
this way is the worst of all seven
siblings seven offers their parents were
murdered by Islamic state the oldest of
them just 17 is now head of the family
now the children are leading a dismal
life in the county to have no one left
well I sure sorry I'm too young to
shoulder this responsibility it's very
very hard for me undo my soul yeah are
you sure i Sabbah i left my only dream
is to have my parents back
rape is an extremely sensitive topic not
only are the women ashamed to talk about
what was done to them many still have
relatives held captive by Islamic state
they fear every interview could be a
death sentence for their sisters or
mothers so we're only showing them
veiled and disclosing neither where we
spoke to them nor their real names
fifteen-year-old bassima was abused for
two months by a so-called Emir and then
sold on to another man the rapist wife
was aware of everything but she didn't
lift a finger to help basima well
Claudia I haven't told anyone about this
except my uncle not even my cousin all I
told him was that I escaped when he did
it to me the first time and has the
demon man i just wanted to die like I do
now I don't have anybody left why this
isn't a life I'm leading I miss my
family my little brother my sister's my
father without them I'm lost I don't
know why they did this to me he wasn't a
man well it was a monster wash we asked
how she's doing now that she's in safety
I keep thinking about my sister who's
still in mazel with is I can't stop
thinking something in me is out of
control I can't do anything about it
what did she think of the time we asked
I'm just a girl what have I done wrong
another girl lies feebly on a mattress
on the floor this morning she underwent
surgery after three months of being
raped only her sisters zeyneb and haneen
feels strong enough to talk about their
tormance another sister is still in the
hands of Islamic state apparently in the
Syrian city of raka testimony from the
hell that Mosul has become wasn't one I
tried to persuade him not to but I
couldn't stop him he was too strong I
tried to push him away but he was
stronger than me I cried out and begged
him to stop but he took a plastic hose
and beat me black and blue I can't
describe what happened I wished I were
dead these aren't human beings if they
were human they wouldn't have done this
to us girls
I can't listen my son it's your Bennett
does she think she can ever lead a
normal life again maybe someday the
Yazidi say this is the 73rd time they
faced the possibility of genocide and
this time it's worse than ever before
since the massacres in August ceremonies
have been discontinued religious life is
at a standstill not even weddings take
place in view of the small religious
community sufferings the temple
attendance still carry out one important
ritual even now rain or shine they light
the 365 candles in the large temple
complex always just before sunset it's
supposed to preserve the light of the
Sun deep into the night
I